[Music]
I'm Mary Helen Bauer's founder of Valley
beautiful fitness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I danced with New York City Ballet for
ten years
Valley Beautiful is really born from my
experience as a professional dancer and
that whole life experience of being a
dancer which is so incredibly physical
where you are using your body to express
your art and I had to learn and it took
a lot of trial and error for me to
figure out the best system to take care
of my body to prevent injury to feel my
strong as my leanest and my best once I
left the company I took a break from
down saying I needed time where I wasn't
in a dance studio where I didn't have
that pressure to look a certain way to
perform a certain way and when I wanted
to start working out I had gained weight
my body had changed I also didn't want
to go back into a ballet studio I felt
self-conscious so I started picking up
with my old exercises I would do 45
minutes a day and my body started to
change
I got leaner and really all of my ballet
muscles kind of came back into use and
with that process my whole body began to
change I started sharing my workout with
friends all of our clients have really
been built through word of mouth
one of the first Victoria's Secret
Angels that I worked with was Miranda
Kerr who is a longtime client and a very
dear friend of mine we're still working
together today and it's been fun to
train with people like Miranda and like
Lily Aldridge through having a baby
through maybe a second pregnancy
for some people it's through multiple
seasons of doing a show like Victoria's
Secret or a big film or runway moment
but it's been really exciting too for me
to take these women through some really
momentous moments and their careers and
be there to support them to help them
feel strong to help them feel confident
and perform at their best level as well
with the Angels they're training really
really hard I'm using ballet inside the
workout but I'm thinking of it as like a
really really focused crazy
I want the deepest burn I want to give
them the biggest impact we're trying to
make their abs as toned as possible to
make their butts as lifted and toned as
possible to give them like sleek
definition through their legs and
beautiful posture and strength to hold
those weightings for example which
really weigh a lot so it's not that I'm
giving them a workout that someone else
couldn't do but certainly we are doing a
really intensified version of the
program a mutual friend that I had
danced with with New York City Ballet
connected me with Natalie she was in
town she was looking for a new trainer
and for somebody to help prepare her for
Black Swan she danced really seriously
until she was about 12 or 13 when her
acting career took off so we had to kind
of bring her up to speed with her
dancing Black Swan
I think played a huge role in bringing
ballet into the spotlight making it cool
making a hip and relevant and pop
culture and of course
Natalie's role in that was huge and I
was so fortunate to have been such a big
part of that film and it also brought
ballet fitness and to enter the press
into I think the sort of lexicon of the
everyday woman
we don't have to be a professional
dancer or to have trained your body for
a dozen years to experience ballet to
bring it into your home you feel better
you have more energy your body feels
stronger you start to see results it's
really really motivating and as you get
going you can build that momentum to
make Fitness more regular part of your
life a larger part of your life you can
prioritize and it takes some work to say
I'm gonna carve this time out just for
me don't wait for life to be perfect
because it's busy and messy and you just
have to start where you are